okay really
my name is Rick Kido I'm 24 years old
and I'm doing master finite I am from
the south of Vietnam and from Osaka Ho
Chi Minh City I don't like that now a
week before the students strike my
friend asked me so Vicki you're gonna
try that they brought me to Chinese
University on the first day of the
strike and I found that pretty amazing
because I never this was my first time
joining any strike at home like any
protest I saw a lot of artwork and I saw
a lot of creative ideas that the
students and young people have been
doing filming is important they create
the filmmakers point of view about the
city about political and social
situation
my name is I'm thinking and I come from
Shanghai I have been Hong Kong about for
two months I decided to take my
documentary about this project I never
saw this activities or or something in
mainland because we can't do that I've
filmed some students exchange students
Camille
maybe a little nervous when I shoot him
I'm very afraid that's others fine I
didn't support them most of mainland
exchanger students they think it's
useless the whole activity is useless
I'm Emma's answer and I was born in Hong
Kong
I'm the fourth generation in Hong Kong
we have food beer food actually a friend
of us the donated food we have it from a
fan in Indian friends so they also
support the cause thank you so I know
everyone is hungry are everywhere
they're eating us biscuits and all that
is food we knew it's a bit risky we are
the very easy target ethnic minorities
all Chinese there and few faces of
Kostis is like easy argument but we had
to take a risk
because we have to show that fear also
part of the community and we want
changes in Hong Kong for our family for
our upcoming generations the more
friends I have from local the more I
know that Ortoli like Hong Kong people
they are not happy at all and now I can
see it way the people struggle to live
they cannot pay their rent and I thought
Hong Kong would be beautiful like
diamond made after the teargas incident
I was kind of shocked
young people actually is the most
important factor in changing the society
maybe now they cannot make any
Chancellor in the future what we fight
for is our future generation so it
should be good
my roommate John yeah she wants me to
join joining them yeah it's more
important for student to study then go
to this track maybe my documentary could
tell what's happening Hong Kong and to
maintain students maybe I think might
hope you documentary couldn't a show in
public in Milan
what I found attractive of a Hong Kong
is that at night you can see the shadow
of the city in the shadow of yourself so
I just like film exactly the shadow of
me I still feel like an outsider that's
right I feel my shadow instead of myself
because like a lot of people saying like
why are you even fight for Hong Kong
it's not your city I'm living here so
somehow the shadow still belonged there
it's still there in Vietnam we always
hope that we can kind of like I stepped
from China from the big shadow of China
when I stay in Hong Kong I think it's a
chance for me because I cannot do that
in Vietnam after we open them everyone
was like around there taking pictures
and outlet okay there we go
people were clapping yelling all of you
are also Hong Kong people and and it was
it happened for the first time all these
years I actually found out back home and
I asked my dad have you ever heard these
things from any of your local friends
about I you think now so everyone came
up to us over like GES up you in and we
all make Hong Kong together and then it
it was very warm we were surprised we
were amazed and we had some friends with
us actually she really started to cry
and she were like wow people are
accepting us
good it's a good thing for men and
students to know what happened in Hakka
yeah but there-there is no opportunity
as what a pity the strike actually bring
all the students of Hong Kong together
everyone would try to be a community
that I think which is a utopia that we
are trying to achieve here
you